good morning remember Tom from moments
of yellow
we're often where we up to so have you
worked at we all schedulers have you
looked at them and a little bit because
we've got all those sessions on
Wednesday yeah so Elon Musk is giving a
talk and Tuesday oh yeah and then the
guy who's the paseo of the X Prizes is
there on Monday so I'd like to get you
there yeah yeah they're always got
stubble
every time when we're talking about
schedule as I mentioned style it's very
frankly why they're coming you checking
this is deep it is we have been friends
for how long have we known each other 40
odd years
this is a David lives on my right you
might remember him from my drama life
video he was the one actually no it
didn't draw you I drew an imperial
Aquila and talked about you Michaels I
somewhat dismissively refer to him as
friend I used to walk to school it just
definitely like understating it so David
counts the conference from Bristol do
your PhD what's that you're getting a
talk what's the talk on in layman's
terms it's I'm using a satellite much
lovers
are you nervous okay we're on the way to
the gate which is about far away from
here as it's possible to like physically
be
I was like 2001 what a hunkered jerk can
make the Kessel run and fight how have
you passed out five pass accident
economy or the careers it doesn't matter
because parsec is a unit of distance
David is pores locked into Attack
Position
hell yeah rogue leader David just to
point out we are in fact coming up a
ramp to get onto our plane that is to on
the upper deck but never chrono easily
have your Bible for the for any
questions please let me ask another
probe thank you
I don't think much of the screens
they've given us I think they didn't
seem terribly interactive go on Mary
let's focus
come on that's my face that's my vision
looks like at the moment it's just
really blurry oh come on you useless
cake we made it
bring California David other girls
unforgettable
so we just made it through we've hit to
the bags they're all down here I've been
entrusted with them all whilst they all
go to the loo that was a really long
flight really long and it was a bit
weird like everybody I mean there was
loads of good stuff on the entertainment
screens like movies and stuff but it was
bit like wall-e with all the people
watching the screens bit strange really
and currently my body thinks it's 3
o'clock 4 o'clock in the morning and is
actually 8 apparently
yay
we're finding the hotel we had a bit of
a pull over an issue of people basically
the university's paying covers but they
haven't had any money so I just have to
spot this the university's gonna have to
pay me back
I really hope they do but look at this
nobody's really cool and check this out
in the street behind me I don't know I
want to say like a classic imrad
computer so we were like neon street
signs and stuff proper city stuff I
think but I am unbelievably ready for
sleep it's really really nice I can't
get over how good the weather is soon as
we arrived so Nina Nina incidentally is
a PhD student register she's getting a
Tokra poster poster who has the
displeasure of living with me and you've
most do not appear in any of my videos
yet but yeah so we're gonna go and try
and find some big American breakfast or
something and then I think we might
because it's raining we're gonna do
registration and then we might were
going to the Exploratorium this is your
first time in America what your first
like initial thoughts your observations
things are being yes this is very deep
cultural commentary we'll get more out
of you as the week goes no they're
really appreciating
right so that's breakfast sausage just
met a seal although it's called SC dog
I don't think I can describe how excited
I started
so I just ruined Nina getting a picture
of a falling water drop but I think
you're like is the fact if you look at
the water drop there isn't a little
upside down time
the future HD
so we're just walking back to the hotel
and tom has been dropping fact bombs
because on the way here he did research
on the plane he watched the film san
andreas was it caught Nob Hill no pale
Nob Hill is so there we go we've learned
something about something yeah the film
which has Dwayne the rock Johnson has
been in character yeah it's full of
scientific inaccuracies and say it says
our geologist friend we actually don't
know that so yeah that's one the
Exploratorium and cons how the ticks
we've already better to do some science
at some point today so something else
which is worth saying is that I mean ie
probably more than anyone else you've
seen in this video is more than a little
bit obsessed with movies and I think
when you're talking about America you in
Borneo in America you think about like I
don't know take the Avengers for example
you see things I think all that's how it
is in the Avengers you know they have
those grills with steam rising out of
them and you kind of I think I have to
be slightly fetishize it in a way I
think that in that way the geography
turn you fetishize those bits of culture
and that you associate them with the
film's you think oh I like this it's
like being in a film and that distance
is new for me
the fact they are actually living there
people who live here do exactly the same
things that people in the UK do
it's just that they do things which you
recognize from movies and maybe but that
wears off after a while
maybe Wayne I don't know it's
interesting so something which I'm
feeling about this lift yeah it makes it
all of that is science although that's
the Moscone Center north-south that's
the most Coney Center north and that's
the Moscone Center West all of that all
of this apart from the cinema just the
stylus place is science and we're in the
middle of all these skyscrapers and the
children's creativity museum behind Tom
over there look at this look at a
science it's gonna happen here 25,000
people got to come here so for more
perspectives this is the whole room
where all the posters are going
is perhaps there well 3200 places for
posters like one of those boards like
that one maybe that's going to be us I'm
hoping my personal sticks somebody's
post is already up someone is really
keen this is the the night of the first
day something is really really keen
Thank You random lady you're probably
someone really important we don't know
who you are sorry Oh poster we've put
Tom and I picked up our posters and it's
got dark in the meantime yeah
I'll unfold this bad boy in a minute but
you have travelled quite a bit how does
America compare to the rest of the world
it's similar enough
yeah everything's to liking the big-city
aspect so in its lacking an extra yeah
it looks a bit different for me it's
food like the variety of restaurant the
fibers like Asian meets Western
portraits I mean I've had a sushi Rito
which is a sushi burrito that's quite
interesting where else are you going to
have you put the burritos on admission
and you've got the sushi
we're all quite big fans really aren't
we now that layer between ten kilometers
and fifty comms announced you is what we
call a stratosphere and it accounts for
almost the entirety of the remaining
mass of the atmosphere see ya let's see
if I can remember this all if you want
more videos with John and I just talking
about stuff then please comment below
make sure you go and look at that
singing playlist of choral music about
Christmas comment below with which one
pieces your favorite you know just have
a listen to a few and shuffle
oh wow no you look at it this way look
at me I'm hideous
and I'm gonna get right in or not that's
amazing